here's Chuck Schumer and Mitch is very
happy to work with Chuck it's odd they
hate each other on everything they're
always fighting when it comes to
spending all of our money and getting us
more in debt and doing things that will
do no good for anyone and helping a
comedian actor in Ukraine hang out with
Ben Stiller and David Letterman then
they agree and they really love each
other it's really fantastic here's Chuck
Schumer being asked well could is it
possible that anyone even read this
freaking thing
to build this morning expect to vote on
it tomorrow but most of Congress hasn't
had a chance to review look the bill has
been carefully worked on by the
Appropriations Committee for a very very
long time most of the provisions of the
bill were well known weeks and weeks and
weeks in advance and getting this bill
done for the American people which
really matters is the most important
thing yes God everything he says is live
first off this does nothing for the
American people this will make
everything worse for the America people
he is not for the American people
McConnell is not for the American people
if I'm an American you you people have
nothing to do with any of the things
that I believe in and man the swamp has
to be drained like they're making more
of an argument for Trump than Trump can
make for himself that's really what's
going on here it's incredible what these
people are doing uh also this idea that
it was bounced around the Appropriations
Committee so everyone knew what was in
it you know it's funny I am a I would
say I'm a fairly astute person when it
comes to watching the news and I pay
attention to these things I'm on Twitter
I have the phone in my hand all the time
I never saw any of this stuff why didn't
any of this stuff get leaked remember
when Roe vaid decision that thing got
leaked we never found out who leaked it
that's kind of weird but everything gets
leaked everything is leaked to the New
York Times but somehow all of the
spending that didn't get leaked until
they released it at 2 A.M that's what
they do and also a 2 A.M Tuesday release
do you know who else does that when
Google and Apple update your terms of
service and they tell you subtly that
you're going to lose some rights or some
free Free Speech or some ability to do
something they're going to do something
Shady they're going to track you you
know what time they do it 2 A.M on
Tuesdays that's pretty much how this
thing works